fin de la semaine dernière à paris
monsieur christian fouchet ministre de
l'éducation nationale recevez les doyens
des facultés des sciences de province au
cours de cette réunion il devait être
question de la rentrée universitaire
1964 du plan d'aménagement des facultés
des sciences en province et nous avons
demandé à monsieur le doyen roubaud
doyenne de la faculté des sciences de
nancy de nous préciser qu'elle avait été
exactement la teneur et la substance de
ses conversations avec monsieur question
foucher s'ils vont s'en tient exactement
aux termes de la lettre dans laquelle
monsieur le directeur général d'avril
nous avait demandé de bien vouloir nous
rendre incomprise monsieur foucher il
devait s'agir est uniquement aux
principes des conditions dans lesquelles
elle se présentera à la rentrée 1964 en
se plaçant tant au point de vue des
bâtiments que des maîtres nécessaires
pour assurer cette rentrée mais nous
imaginions volontiers et qu'il s'agirait
également de connaître un peu notre
sentiment en ce qui concerne les
réformes et l'enseignement supérieur
actuellement à l'étude par la commission
dite commission des 18 et c'est
effectivement ce qui s'est passé en ce
qui concerne nancy monsieur le doyen et
quels ont été les projets qui sont
retenus en ce qui concerne nancy le gros
problème c'est de faire démarrer avant
de nouvelles vrai que des sciences et le
bâtiment de propédeutique il est en
retard d'un an
il nous faut absolument qu'il soit prêt
pour la rentrée 1965
en ce qui concerne ans il ya eu quelques
retards monsieur boucher nous a promis
de faire le nécessaire en ce qui
concerne les m j'ai attiré son attention
sur le fait qu'à nancy
nous avions cette école supérieure
d'ingénieurs c'est une des facultés des
france qui en a le plus et qu'il fallait
songer
non seulement vous m pour la faculté des
sciences maître de conférences ce maître
assistant en particulier les aussi à
tous les maîtres nécessaire pour les
écoles nationales supérieures
d'ingénieurs
je vous remercie beaucoup monsieur le
guen